hey guys what kind of friends do you
have
this is important because iron sharpens
iron
do you realize how some guys become
better when they hang out with good men
good friends and then have some change
for the worst because they hang out with
the wrong friends
we call that toxic relationships and
most of us when we look at this we
usually do not look at ourselves we only
look at other people so what if this
person who's influencing people to be
worse is actually you
what if it's you and you just can't see
it clearly how are you influencing your
friends
but if it's not you let me give you 10
signs to identify when you might be in a
toxic relationship
bad friends only call when they need
help you know some people just call you
when they need advice or help but you
never hear them calling you just to hear
how things are going
why is that because they're selfish they
only care about themselves they don't
really care about you they only call
when they want you to help them or when
they want you to listen to their
problems it's only about them them them
they never want to ask you how it's
really going with you because they don't
really care
and second they're just using you
they're just using you in those times
when they need help
they're only there when life is good you
know those kind of people they just want
to spend time with you when it's fun you
know when it's good for them when you
spend money
and when a lot of things are just free
and these kind of people
are never there when times are tough
when you're actually going through a
rough time and need a good friend
ask yourself were they there when you
lost a family member were they they when
you lost your job were they there when
you went through a breakup or a divorce
were they there when you asked for help
think about this carefully are they here
for me only when there are good times or
do they help me up when I'm down
you can never be yourself
I mean that's why friends are there for
people you can talk to where you can be
yourself and if you feel like you can't
be yourself you always feel like you
need to impress them to keep them as
your friends
hmm it might not be your real friends
this is how some friendships work in
school
and College
and even after that
no a real friend accepts you as you are
but
I also encourage you motivate you and
build you up to become better
the best man that you can be
they never take responsibility and
actually certain people actually turn it
back on you
these are the kind of people you want to
stay away from especially when they do
you wrong and then they cannot take
responsibility for it you know those
people who cannot take honest critique
they always have excuses and even make
you feel bad for even pointing out their
faults for doing you wrong some of these
people are like good actors they're
playing the role of a victim they're
victimizing themselves trying to make
you feel bad very manipulative
no good friends will take responsibility
for their actions especially when it
influences you personally that is if
they truly care about you
when they purposefully say things that
hurt you
these are those kind of guys who want to
bring you down so that they may feel
better about themselves they enjoy
repeatedly saying things that offend and
hurt you and they know it
this is actually sick it is pure evil
move away from these kind of people and
find friends who will actually Build You
Up
they want you to prioritize them but
they won't prioritize you these are the
kind of people you don't want to make
friends with because they will never
care about you they just use you they
want you to jump whenever they can
benefit from something that you can do
for them at a specific time
they get jealous easily these are bad
friends and most of the time they don't
have confidence in themselves in who
they are but they compare themselves to
you and they want what you have for some
reason
be careful here because especially when
you
get credit or you get praised in public
then they get jealous and they they want
to steal it they want to have what you
have
that is not love that is not friendship
people who are jealous can backstab you
very easily they want to be in your
place they want to experience what
you're experiencing they want to have
what you have
or they would rather not let you have
something if they cannot have it as well
they betray your trust
this is a tough one
especially when you trust them with your
secrets with your weaknesses and then
they actually use it against you the
Bible says a dishonest man spreads
strife and a Whisperer separates close
friends
good friends are those who keep their
word
bad friends
change like the weather stay away from
people who one day treat you like their
best friend and the next day like
someone they don't even know these are
also those kind of friends who act a
certain way when you are with them alone
but in totally different when you're
with other people in a group setting
good friends are consistent
they are causing you more stress instead
of reducing it
guys life can be tough at times so in
those tough times you need your friends
they should not make it worse the Bible
says a man of many companions may come
to ruin but there is a friend who sticks
closer than a brother you cannot choose
your family but you can definitely
choose your friends and it might feel
really hard tough to move away from a
toxic relationship because you're just
so in that situation that you don't see
things clearly but you need to move away
for you to be able to improve and make
better friends both friendships with the
right kind of people
because remember
the Bible says iron sharpens iron and
one man sharpens another now remember to
subscribe if you haven't done so already
and you might like one of these videos
here and before you go always remember
this
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys